j'ai vu monsieur pandro protesté qui se
plaisait dans ce poulailler c'est vrai
que lui parler à des poulets avant et
non pas des étudiants
monsieur ma mère
c'est une ambiance de basse-cour c'est
une ambiance de basse-cour et je dénonce
Monsieur Hollande
la facilité et je dirais même en vous
regardant la lâcheté
la lâcheté qu'il y a dans votre attitude
asseyez-vous je le redis la lâcheté ah
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
jamais
assumer arrêter
[Applaudissements]
tous les Français le président de
l'Assemblée nationale évacué par les
huissiers
les députés socialistes assez trousse
qui le poursuivent jusqu'à l'entrée de
ses appartements privés
bloquée par le service de ordre il se
retourne à leur écrit leur colère
sous le gouvernement de Monsieur
Schroeder a fait plutôt les réformes que
nous sommes en train de faire en ce
moment
au Président Jacob se dirigeant vers moi
ma qualifié d'hystérique alors cher
prions Jacob vous auriez pu être plus
franc et faire comme dans les cours
d'école me traitait de
[Musique]
sur l'air de à cause des garçons et
j'écoutais oui à cause des petites cônes
parce que c'est bien le minimum traité
des parlementaires de petites cônes sur
les réseaux sociaux est à la fois
sexiste et insultant